and there's plenty of news to tell you
about this morning tax investigators in
New York State are looking into a
bombshell report that appears to
undermine four decades of self-promotion
by President Trump the New York Times
investigation says the president
apparently received the equivalent of at
least 413 million dollars from his
father's real estate empire much of it
through tax dodges mr. Trump has always
claimed to be a self-made billionaire it
was a central theme of his 2016 campaign
I got a very very small loan from my
father many years ago I built that into
a massive empire and I paid my father
back that alone The Times calls some of
the tax schemes out right fraud the
president's lawyer says there was no
fraud or tax evasion by anyone Paula
Reid is at the White House with more on
this story Paula good morning this was
big news this is big news the New York
Times says it reviewed over a hundred
thousand financial documents and they
found that in every era of the
president's life his finances were
dependent on his father's wealth as you
just heard the president has long
claimed that a million-dollar loan is
what jump-started his empire but The
Times found that he received at least
sixty million dollars in loans from his
father which he did not pay back in full
and much of his wealth was acquired by
participating in what the Times calls
dubious tax schemes among them mr. Trump
and his siblings set up a sham
corporation to disguise gifts from their
parents and helped his father take
improper tax deductions and help
formulate a strategy to undervalue his
parents real estate holdings in all the
times estimates those maneuvers helped
the Trump family avoid paying at least
five hundred and fifty million dollars
in gift and inheritance taxes they
instead paid just over 50 million
dollars but an attorney for the
president called The Times allegations
of fraud and tax evasion 100 percent
false and highly defamatory the White
House issued an unusual statement they
called the article a misleading attack
but then went on to list the president's
many accomplishments and take some shots
at the New York Times now the statute of
limitations for any criminal charges has
passed if these allegations turn out to
be true but there is a possibility of
civil fines
John all that Thanks